BUT FIRST, WHEN #MeToo BECOMES
HE TOO.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
JUST A FEW HOURS AFTER THE
NEW YORKER BROKE ITS STORY
CHARGING NEW YORK DEMOCRATIC
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN WITH ABUSING FOUR
WOMEN, HE RESIGNED HIS OFFICE.
NOW ISN'T IT RICH THAT HE SET
HIMSELF UP AS THE HERO OF THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT BY USING HIS
OFFICE TO SUE HARVEY WEINSTEIN?
>> WOMEN WERE COERCED INTO
FACILITATING HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
MISCONDUCT, SOMETIMES THEY WERE
TARGETS THEMSELVES.
IF THEY REFUSED THEY WERE
THREATENED.
THEY KNEW HOW PERVASIVE IT WAS
AND NOT ONLY DID THEY FAIL TO
STOP IT, THEY ENABLED IT AND
COVERED IT UP.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING AS
DESPICABLE AS WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
HERE.
>> Laura: I GUESS IT TAKES ONE
TO NO ONE.
SCHNEIDERMAN WAS ALSO THE
DARLING OF THE ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA
AND FELLOW DEMS FOR CHALLENGING
DONALD TRUMP'S NEARLY EVERY MOVE
DONALD TRUMP'S NEARLY EVERY MOV
MOVE.
HE HAS FILED OVER 100 LAWSUITS
OR ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO
STOP HIS DACA PLAN, THE TRAVEL
BAN, HEALTH CARE DEREGULATION.
IT WENT ON AND ON.
IF SCHNEIDERMAN QUICKLY BECAME A
CHAMPION OF THE LEFT RESISTANCE,
A KIND OF SUPERHERO, WHICH WAS
HOW COMEDIAN AND FAN GIRL
SAMANTHA BEE ATTEMPTED TO FRAME
HIM ON THIS NOW SCRUBBED EPISODE
OF HER SHOW.
>> OH, MY GOD, .
>> SCHNEIDERMAN, SCHNEIDERMAN.
>> YOU WERE GOING TO SAVE US.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO IT BUT
THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF PEOPLE
OTHER THAN STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL GETTING
ENGAGED.
>> Laura: DEPENDS ON WHAT
GETTING ENGAGED MEANS.
NEXT TIME, SAMANTHA, BUT BE
CAREFUL.
THAT'S SO BAD.
DID WE REALLY WRITE THAT?
NEXT TIME DO A BETTER JOB
CHOOSING YOUR SUPERHEROES.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, HE DID LIKE TO
DRESS UP APPARENTLY, SO MAYBE
THIS SUPERHERO THING DOES WORK.
WHILE HE TRIES TO EXPLAIN AWAY
THE CHARGES AGAINST HIM THIS
WAY, HE SAID IN THE PRIVACY OF
INTIMATE RELATIONSHIPS I'VE
ENGAGED IN ROLE-PLAYING AND
OTHER CONSENSUAL ACTIVITY.
I HAVE NOT ASSAULTED ANYONE.
SUPERMAN DIDN'T BEAT THE HELL
OUT OF LOIS LANE, ERIC.
FOR WOMEN ROMANTICALLY INVOLVED